peut pas françois a dévoilé aujourd'hui
son encyclique sur l'environnement juin
2015 quelques mois avant la conférence
de paris sur le climat voici le symbole
de la prise de conscience écologique de
l'église catholique
cette lettre du pape françois adressée à
tous les évêques près de 200 pages
entièrement dédiée à la préservation de
l'environnement
une première pour une encyclique papale
françois y accuse l'homme et ses
industries responsables du dérèglement
climatique prescripteurs le pape appelle
à la décroissance dans son texte à
l'abandon du pétrole et du charbon
l'écologie devient alors l'un des enjeux
majeurs du vatican mais avant le pape
françois d'autres avaient déjà montré la
voie en 1970 dans un discours devant les
nations unies
le pape paul 6 évoqué les conséquences
néfastes de l'industrialisation sur
l'environnement jean paul ii prend
ensuite le relais en vie tant
régulièrement la société a changé de
mode de vie en 1988 en voyage à
strasbourg
il s'inquiétait par exemple de la
pollution du rhin
je souhaite que se poursuivent des
efforts positive entrepris pour lutter
contre la pollution du rhin la nature
est mise à notre disposition
sachons être les gestionnaires avisés
respectueux et aime bien qui doit garder
sa fécondité pour les générations à
venir
son successeur
seize consacrer ensuite tout un chapitre
à l'environnement dans l'une de ces en
cycle et en 2008 aux journées mondiales
de la jeunesse de sydney en australie
il faisait part de ses préoccupations
écologiques devant sa cinquante mille
jeunes mais tu m'as des pluies marque la
surface de la terre
l'érosion la déforestation le gaspillage
des ressources minérales et marine et ce
pour alimenter un besoin de consommation
insatiable en 2014 le pape françois
prenait le relais il tirait la sonnette
d'alarmé dans un discours au parlement
européen notre terre en effet besoin de
soins continus et d'attention chacun a
une responsabilité personnelle dans
cette protection de la création
nous sommes certes gardien mais pas
propriétaire de cette neige et
inconséquent nous devons l'aimer et la
respecter malamba drogue un appel papale
entendues dans plusieurs pays
en france par exemple le label église
verte voyait le jour en 2010 est un
outil destiné à encourager les
initiatives écologiques au sein des
paroisses
[Musique]